[Music]
okay what do you say what are you saying
to me shoot huh huh huh oho okay I got
you now
who me huh okay all right I'm gonna
carry on with your video huh huh
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't tax me bro the game
where you have to try to get away from
people trying to stop you from getting
blew away with tax evasion and um beep
oh I'm gonna just you know trying to
back up and be a little less suck ass
about all this let's assume that I'm
good at this game
so it's an endless runner back game
where you gotta hold right and move I
don't know what I'm hitting I don't know
what's going on well I got him and
everything alright [ __ ] dude I'm not
good at this one okay but the point is
Oh was that a missile what the [ __ ] with
that what did you call me I don't know
what's happening but apparently I'm dead
or have major brain damage no it's a
quick endless-runner where you're
supposed to be for some reason you're
running away but also you're collecting
money as you go and he's very persistent
please hop to it would add me I don't
know
thank you you beat him up good I think I
should feel proud about that
okay alright bye then you know I'm gonna
calm down because I need to actually
calmly produce and see what the hell's
going on about me hey hey let's go in to
Sisseton oh I can double jump well
that's awfully nice I didn't know that I
could actually do that so you probably
have played endless runners before and I
mean this isn't exactly different than
that but at least this one's you don't
to pay for it's totally free well if
it's when it leaves damn it
with with this one it live doggy doggy
doggy doggy doggy
ah bird in the face nose broke back
season is right around the corner I
think a very important lesson is to be
learned here you're running away from
the police for you're not yet
tax evasion policies not yet I mean
you're getting all this money I don't
assume that you're actually tax evading
as you're running because why would they
break into your house and then take you
all around the city and then you're
collecting coins that are just laying
everywhere I don't know what's happening
but if we're going back now
alrighty then clearly do I don't know
that did that a bomb I did not mean to
detonate a bomb sure kitty cat you need
to not do that to me Hubbard's don't
come oh I didn't mean that
it's BTA all over again righty then you
know what I probably [ __ ] the bats app
probably shouldn't try to make semi car
[ __ ] semi yeah Starbucks I don't know
semi-competent commentary because
doesn't seem to be working out too well
for me for most of you or a lot of you
you may not even have to worry about
paying taxes just yet cuz you're not 18
once you turn 18 yeah start paying tax
so then mine don't not pay your taxes
because that's bad I mean dead problems
I'm not gonna make any sort of social
commentary about tags and what they are
I mean you know you get it okay here's
the longer the shorter so here here's
Mark Millar's lessons on the social
dynamics and implications of taxes and
the virtues by which they lead our lives
and cause for greater social services
and whatnot and also you know millets it
like that all out in big one piece of
text that's lesson number one of my two
hundred and seventy eight part series
about taxes
taxes where you pay money to the
government to make sure that they can
afford to run the country and that's all
paid to with that's number two for Marg
Lars two hundred and seventy eight part
series about the social dynamic attended
up [ __ ] did you guys copy on saved you a
fallen-down I can't get up you know a
backs kind of broken in 13 places
goodnight
okay that's that's equally as helpful is
getting me out of this pit I've fallen
into I just wanna keep my money
yeah don't won't take anything from me
please please I carry all of my life
savings in a briefcase I'm as cool as
Johnny Bravo come on have a heart yeah
kitty cats Tony don't be a murderous
bastard okay oh who put all these crates
on the ground maybe you can stop the
people that are just laying all this
money around
I mean is it my fault that I'm picking
it all I'm glad one of you ragged it a
cat it up get me yeah again I don't that
it just exploded like I said before I
don't know who's laying about all this
money I don't know what why are there so
many of you it's that but it's not my
fault I was act I'm actually running on
my way to the post office to mail my tag
form because I'm fair why did I hit I
fell in the sewers again sir I seem to
be stuck in a giant hole in the ground
dad does not help me could you throw
down a ladder like you know like a
shovel I could try to tunnel my way out
a different way or if you keep digging
myself in a hole I mean that's an option
too I can do them whoa someone call
lassie are falling in the wall by this
time I'm gonna I'm gonna go for the high
score here my goal being the
guess what blood is possible which is
admirable oat coffee oh that's nice
okay oh oh that darn cat aqui
even they were shocked to see what
happened just their friend who really
actually had a fun I like this endless
under got a lot of obstacles that are
very hard to see which is not common a
lot of these there's a lot of there's
like a slow down mechanic and you know
that's nice other than just instant AI
dot dot degree it's hard to know whether
you're supposed to jump or not I Wow you
shoved me ow my shoulder it's then
impinge oh oh I will not suck and I will
run very hot I am going very far today
now I will not lose - ah damn pack or
will I run away from you I don't know
where I am going but I know that gets
really angry at me and I have my bodies
all around me all the time they will
take a bullet for me if they really want
you I don't know where I'm going but who
the hell put all these boxes in my way
and all these other things that are
strewn about the city maybe the textbook
ergo to attend I'll just [ __ ] when I run
around and don't fall in that hole get
my coffee go real fast
then I'm zooming through the city
grabbing lots of coins no one can stop
me now double coffee yes please espresso
in my ass I've got my buddies all around
me once again this truck is blocking
that hole don't think I didn't see that
didn't see the hole before this what I'm
running very fast now going through the
high core is all good alright I'm done
that's always for don't tax me bro which
is just a demo
there's not even a select character
option or an options menu that hasn't
worked because that's not easy for a
fully fledged King at least he was a lot
of fun it'd be a lot of potential in
this one because it's just interesting I
like it so anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching if you enjoyed my
songs let me know down the comments
below I'm sure they were great weren't
they
huh
I don't even remember what I said okay
so anyway thanks everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]